I never you that wasn't you that wasn't
that was that was me no him no you look
look look look here he me look CL
Chaser clout Chaser he lied about me and
made a video about me guess what I said
he asked me to come him his life when I
went there I was I was talking
about guess what he Ked me and M me and
he said next time come there and he
was nice to see
[Music]
you did you just shake the hands of
kufar you Just sh the hand
is that is that a
problem so the is in the hand yes the
you need to respect others it's part of
the yes no not you not you not you not
you not you not
you time for no that's your
Bible okay so now today so you're talk
I'm not Muslim I walk with
Muslim are you are you going to answer
what theil is yes all right hey guys
he's about to tell us what the angil is
no no no
shall we start with or what trity talk
about what no what is
theity that's me first you got get you
got to get me
me what is the what's the everyone
listen here God logic he uses Quran
verses to justify about
gospels the
the the the
you is that how
they hold it down hold it down hold it
down down hold it down hold it down hold
it down hold it down hold it down down
all right go ahead so now so now what
I'm asking is a chance a chance
Christians always use the Quran verses
and Hadith to justify gospels and Torah
and the Old Testament so
now minut so now so two minutes aie I
can
Des somebody going
time me and him about I'll it
I'll yes go crappy it's going to be good
yes okay well he kind of started so 1
130 scrap yes 2 minutes yeah
minutes
okay Cal down c
c guys guys can you give us can you give
us some
space hold on let me uh let me start
your time over bro go go okay wait wait
wait I got to start a time over I got
start no you don't need to I'm speaking
30 seconds maybe less than promise
talk to each other talk talk to each
other okay so now God logic use the
Quran to justify
inil he wanted he want he justified to
and gospels and Old Testament to use the
Quran yes so in order him to justify
that by using the Quran I want him today
any and God logic to describe what go
and inil and what Torah is according to
Quran
because he claimed he claimed Allah
approved the gospels and what and Old
Testament so I want an evidence from him
to to describe Quran according to Quran
yeah what inil is and what Torah is and
I want references and evidence because
you can't claim any something which you
cannot even describe so I want him to
describe use this to it up to
Quran if he can't describe
is
invalid you
understand okay just tell everybody to
step back now you can
for argument oh yeah yeah you want me to
explain what the is from the I want you
to describe what inil and Old Testament
is Torah according to the Quran and
Hadith to justify your claim that Allah
has approved I didn't make a claim you
said I didn't make a claim yes you said
I got the evidence here okay I have the
evidence I recorded you I got everything
the videos I have didn't you just ask I
just I just I guess I'm use I'm going
use my two minutes to restate the
question asking is asking a question the
same as making a
CLA speaker cor is a different dial he
claimed that Allah has approved gospels
the current gospels he have he has and
the Old Testament so I want him to
describe it's okay it's okay guys
so you're get by
random like that Jesus all right guys so
yes did everybody hear me ask a
question what what was the
question what's the so wait so all y'all
heard me ask
that okay so we gave he got had about a
minute 30 wa wait wait it's
okay it's my turn man hey it's my turn
let me cook let me cook let me cook let
me cook let me cook let me cook
so hold it down hold it down hold it
down hold it down it down hold it down
hold it down so I asked the question
what is the in
and the first thing that our friend does
is ask me a question can you got logic
describe to me what the inal is and the
Old Testament and the New Testament
since you claim and believe that my
Quran affirms your dude I asked what is
the
inal okay that
question 2 minutes minutes
all right so I I I'll land it with this
okay because this is what I will give
him I will give him this I'll tell him
what the Quran says about the inel and
then I'm going to restate my question
okay so the Quran in S three says that
the Quran came confirming what came
before it the Torah and the injil a
guidance beforehand for mankind chapter
5:47 let the people of
the judge by what Allah has
revealed
therein so let the people of the Gospel
judge by the gospel right
568 oh people of the book you have
nothing to stand on unless you observe
the Torah and the
what and all that has been revealed so
not just that but all the prophets the
Psalms all the books okay so this is
what the Quran says what is the angel a
revelation given to Jesus for mankind
now my question is what is
[Music]
the in one minut in 1
minute 3 2 1 go go
I asked him to describe what inil and
Torah is according to Quran and Hadith
he didn't describe it because if you
claim something you need to prove
evidence otherwise you can't just speak
empty words and using the Quran without
context we need context what matters is
context so now so the
vers the verses he used Quran chapter 5
verse 68 he's reading the first bit of
the verse Allah mentioned in that verse
Torah and and the Quran no it doesn't
yes no it doesn't show me where it says
Allah all the people of the
book not you are upon nothing unless
you until you
all that's been
red did y hear Quran yes the verse I'm
reading what is been revealed to you all
no it says and all that's been revealed
not the Prophet this verse is talking
about all the Torah in and the Quran so
Christians read only that one again we
need context what's
inil it has description chapter 7 verse
157 example Allah told us Prophet
Muhammad is mentioned written written
here in the previous books which is
Torah and inil in order in order Torah
and inil to be the current one which
Christians have now I want them to show
me Prophet Muhammad where it's written
in current Torah and inil which they
claim that's
description one description round two
beautiful so guys he made a okay 3 all
right he made a slight mistake in 568 it
doesn't say anything about the Quran it
says all that's been revealed it doesn't
mention the Quran there you read you
quote it in an Arabic the word Quran is
not there but I appreciate you affirming
that the Quran talks about all of our
Bible because it's not it's not just
it's not just the Torah it's not just
the Torah it's not just the inel but all
that's been revealed that's the Psalms
that's Jeremiah that's Isaiah Ezekiel
Malachi and so on and soth so all the
Bible it's Paul the writings of Paul the
whole new testament right so that's
number one here's number two guys number
two I love how he admitted that the
Quran says the inil is with
us that's what he said he said it's he
said it's with us hold on it's all good
hold it down hold it down yeah we WR the
book that's right so so guys you got so
it's it's with on we good we good it's
with us right so he says that Muhammad
is written with them in the Torah and
the inil now this is his challenge his
challenge is I want you if it's talking
about what you have show me where
Muhammad is in your gospel that you have
today actually it doesn't work like that
because if he's not in there then the
Quran is
false cuz your Quran lied your Quran
didn't know what was in the gospel okay
so what this shows is is that one
Muhammad didn't know what the nil was or
what was in it and neither does sage cuz
he hasn't answered the question what is
the in
jail when he's talking you're not
shouting
it hold it
it list Ladies sorry yeah his time is
done though ladies and gentlemen very
mind he can't drink this milk
because okay when your time's ready yes
oh
yes so now number one now he failed to
prove what in and Torah is according to
Quran I said Allah describ tah and
number one Allah said Tor in Prophet
Muhammad is mentioned that it's written
not written written yeah it's written
there it's written so now in order the
his gospels to be theil which the one
which Allah has approved we need to find
Prophet Muhammad there if he's not there
then Allah is talking about about
another inil not the one he
has resuming now okay number two inil is
not written in Greek language chapter
Quran Chapter 14 verse no you the one
you have it I'm refuting yours yours I'm
refuting Yours listen listen the one
Allah revealed to Jesus is not written
in Greek language the one they have it
now the original manuscript they said is
written in Greek Quran
14:4 Allah said we have never sent a
messenger unless we sent him with his
with the with his own tongue his
people's language
to be the gospels the one they have it
now should be written in the tongue of
Jesus and his people and Allah said
Jesus was only sent according to inil
was only sent to the people of
Israelites chap Quran chapter 3 verse 49
the one you have it Jesus was sent to
Gentiles so we have different inil in my
inil is not the one you have it simple
okay
okay thank you no okay so now my
challenge again the book you are
describing we need context come up with
your
Contex round three you heard the
question yeah I heard question got
answer the question let's see what you
do starting now SJ how do you know what
language the was SP was
written I'm going to use my time to let
you answer what what language was it WR
asking yeah what what language was the
his own language it's not okay no what
was it it's not Greek what was it
Israelite language what was it the
language
Hebrews what was it Hebrew it was Hebrew
okay okay okay guys okay I'm aric to you
Hebrew and aramic yes okay wa no you
said that I didn't say that so wait so I
just need I want to misrepresent you so
the language of Jesus was Hebrew and
Aramaic yes okay all right guys okay so
yeah you
me langes all right no according to them
you two languages I said according to
him no no no you said that you said
that's your answer from the Hebrew
scriptures you you said that's your
answering to him no no don't say
according to me so see this is why I got
to do this again so I asked saraj what
language was the inil written in Jesus
he says it was in Jesus's language I
said what was that he said Hebrew and
Aramaic but then now his his Escape is
according to you I didn't did I say what
his language
okay all right all right slow it down so
let's let's see his answer again what
was Jesus's language Jesus language was
Israelites language what was in
Hebrew Hebrew yes all right so not me to
you see okay but Hebrew you're going to
give a Hebrew all right good so we're
going with Hebrew so Jesus spoke in
Hebrew where in the Quran does it say
that okay okay I can answer shall I
answer okay just please first do you
want to end your time you can pause it
cuz I have I have a followup question
okay so same question applies to him
show me in the Bible speak GRE
language show me why in the Bible Jesus
used to speak Hebrew same question I'm
asking same question show me where Jesus
spoke Greek in your Bible I got you I
got you okay so got it did anybody hear
me say what language Jesus spoke no okay
what's his
language what's his language to you
what's his language
language
language my friend my friend I'm coming
I'm coming I'm coming language I'm
coming I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming
wait for me wait for me okay we're so
yeah yeah wait for me wait for me wait
for me so and because he's incapable of
answering this question cuz his Quran
doesn't tell him look this is why this
is important he's trying to tell me what
the inal is not when he can't tell me
what the inil is you see so he has to
say oh it was written in Jesus's
language what was that he can't tell me
Hebrew wait where does your Quran tell
me that well where does your Bible say
he spoke this I never said anything so
notice what was Jesus
[Applause]
language all respect you got about 15
seconds left yeah so guys I was able to
deal with things he said in the
beginning but now I'm not going to
tolerate any more questions on his side
because let me what wases language can't
go my
God so I asked a few question guys what
was my first question what is what was
my second
question what language did Jesus speak
right and and then the third one was
what was the language that theel was
written let's see if in this 2 minutes
he answers one at least one at least one
at least one I'm sorry I I didn't it say
three I should have have said three I
should have said three I I should have
said three I should have said three I
should Christians
always the
language yes Christians always claim
what Jesus language is Greek he asked me
a challenge he said to me he asked me to
show me he asked me to show me that Jes
what was the language of Jesus the Quran
yes so same thing applies to him I want
him to show me what language Jesus used
to speak what was his mother language
what was his people's language from the
Bible he can't show me so now we agree
both of us we agree the language of
Jesus his mother language his own tongue
is not Greek he cannot prove it wrong we
know the language of Jesus is is is
Hebrew we know the language of Jesus is
not is not Greek we know the people of
of Jesus are not Greek people so now in
order the gospels to be the ones he have
gospel and inil in order inil to be the
ones he have now the gospels not gospel
yeah I want him to show me
what language was Jesus Jesus used to
speak now Quran affirms two things Jesus
was sent to the people of Israelites not
to Greek not to Gentiles Jesus language
was not Greek because his people were
Israelites therefore his mother language
his people's language definitely 100%
according to Quran is not Greek we agree
me and him I and him now it's not Greek
the language of Jesus and Jesus was not
I don't remember hearing so and the
Bible is not for Gentiles so the
description according to Islam ofil and
the description of gospels is different
so you cannot use Quran to justify your
point when the Quran is describing in
different ways than your
gospels so what language was Jesus used
to speak I described inil and I said
inil is not it's not written in Greek
but I use the Quran and I said
it's for Jesus speak people not Gentiles
I answer so now what's my
question what's my
question what my question your question
doesn't matter bro now what's my
question can I talk what language was
Jes in what book show me from the Bible
that Jesus used to speak Aramaic or
Greek his own language mother language
is Greek you exra hold on hold on Greek
I want Greek first of
all he didn't he didn't say anything
about I'm asking asking him to answer
what was the language of Jesus does it
matter yes it doesn't matter it's like
me speaking in Arabic and
IR can I go so Jesus spoke Chinese as
well can I can I go it doesn't make
sense he hey he speaks Arabic though
Jesus spoke
Arabic never knew how to speak Greek I
challenge any Christian to show me from
the Bible what's your native tongue any
Christian to show me from the Bible that
Jesus used to speak question question
answer
ask I'm
asking a then you can ask me so you
don't have a answer I guess he can all
right so guys what was the language of J
this be it this will be it the language
of Jesus okay all right guys so um I
don't this is what I this is probably
why like he says he came to my Tik Tok
and he says that I muted him and then I
kicked him out this would be why this
will be why because literally this
brother has not answered a single
question I had three of them three
simple ones and I'm sorry for saying
three my Muslim friends but I had three
simple questions what is the NG what
language was it written in and what was
the language of Jesus he couldn't answer
a single one so what am I supposed to do
here what what what what what we doing
here man come on man come on man so look
let me let me tell you guys why this is
important all right cuz you look look
look look you guys all of you guys all
of you guys listen listen listen all of
you guys can use this as an argument
against any de because they will sound
as brilliant as SJ did today I promise
you all you got to do ask them don't
tell them what the gospel is don't give
them nothing just ask them what is the
in jail they can't tell you but listen
what what you can do is you can show
them that the same reasons why they
reject Our Gospel is the same reason
they should reject the inil in the Quran
because let me tell you why they say we
don't know who wrote the gospels do you
know who wrote the angil
no do you know who wrote it do you know
what language it it was it was written
in Greek not in Jesus's tongue do you
know what his tongue was no do you know
what the language of the jail was
written in
no looks like we in the same boat looks
like May
looks like my Anonymous nonnative Hebrew
Aramaic gospel is the same in jail he's
talking about well it's no difference
thanks for coming man let me